[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the island fortress of
azkaban
and the prisoners that reside within it
azkaban was built in the 15th century
and began being used as a detention
facility in the year 1718
housing some of the most sinister
witches and wizards to have ever
disgraced the wizarding world
before the fortress was built azkaban
was just an island
but when its first inhabitant equistus
found the island
he decided to transform it into his own
little dark arts experiment
acrystus was a dark wizard that
practiced the worst forms of dark magic
and he was known to lure sailors to the
island then torched them
before he got there he was crazy but
after spending considerable amount of
time there
he went completely insane over the
course of its history azkaban has been
home to many witches and wizards
including percival dumbledore barty
crouch jr
lucius malfoy bellatrix lestrange marvel
gaunt
and more due to its remote location and
the sea of dementors that stop prisoners
from escaping
it's truly the ultimate prison and if
you are able to escape
then your new fate if caught would be a
dementor's kiss
azkaban is a truly inhospitable
environment the criminals that are sent
there
are there to suffer and wallow in their
own self-pity it's certainly no vacation
home
and in the goblet of fire sirius black
reveals a little bit about what happens
to the prisoners inside
he wasn't the only one said serious
bitterly
most go mad in there and plenty stop
eating in the end
they lose the will to live you could
always tell when a death was coming
because the dementors could sense it
they got excited
so given that most people either die or
go insane
i think that it's safe to say that going
there is a death sentence
in a way it's certainly not structured
as a rehabilitation facility
and it almost seems like the system
surrounds sending people there to suffer
before their inevitable death rather
than just killing them directly
so what's the point what does being in
azkaban prison
actually physically do to people in the
books there are several passages that
describe
characters after their time in azkaban
first
lucius malfoy lucius malfoy looked up
his skin appeared yellowish and waxy in
the firelight
and his eyes were sunken and shadowed
when he spoke
his voice was hoarse then sirius black
if he hadn't known it was the same
person he would never guess it was black
in his old photograph
his face wasn't sunken and waxy but
handsome full of laughter
if eyes hadn't been shining after the
deep dark sockets he might have been a
corpse
the waxy skin was stretched so tightly
over the bones of his face
it looked like a skull his yellow teeth
were bared in a grin
his voice sounded as though he had long
since lost the habit of using it
and even bellatrix are strange she
retained vestiges of great good looks
but something perhaps azkaban had taken
most of her beauty
so what's the common theme here from the
looks of things it looks like it has a
profound effect on the prisoners
both mentally and physically not only
are they stuck there on an island
fortress
surrounded by crashing waves dementors
and the cold stone walls of their cell
but they are also drained of their life
force azkaban is a very dark place
with a history of awful dark magic and
it sounds like some of that magic
actually comes into play when it begins
to strip people of their beauty
they develop yellowish waxy skin a
sunken face
a weak and horse voice and physical
frailty as a result
of their environment and that's it for
this video leave your video suggestions
down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
[Music]
you